I'm Adam and I was on an episode of Come
Dine With Me summer you'll come dine
with me experience you can have more
than one word okay okay that was it cool
yeah yeah no I would I would call it
okay they're a part that are incredibly
boring the best moments the ones that
I'll remember forever are when we all
got kicked out of the last contestants
house
let's see who's won you won Jane dear
Lord what a sad little life Jane but I
hope now you spend it on getting some
lessons in grace and decorum because you
have all the grace of a reversing dump
truck without any tires on take your
money and get off my property quite
fitting that we're here in your bedroom
they look around your bedroom except it
may not have technically been in this
house where I live right now some people
allege and they have no evidence for
this of course that I faked having a
girlfriend in order to use her house to
film my episode that's pure speculation
if I were to speculate why I would do
that it would be because maybe at the
time I lived in college accommodation
with like a tiny bedroom in a tiny
kitchen that you could never have gotten
onto the show so hypothetically one
might say the producers if one of course
was evil and bad which I am NOT that you
have a girlfriend and you're in the
process of moving in with her therefore
you can use your house of course I
didn't do that and that is a pure rumor
my menu was a very American spread
little deep-dish pizzas made in cupcake
tins breakfast burrito that portion was
described as places although he is
universally reviled now so who really
won cookies that had potato chips
crushed into them cookies and milk isn't
is a very American thing biscuits for
pudding
mmm if you're American I don't have to
convince you that cookies and milk are a
normal and good thing to eat but if
you're not just try it
it makes the cookies like slightly mushy
er and more delicious it's sort of like
cereal is better with milk cookies are
the cereal of dessert if you would dunk
it digestive in tea but not a cookie and
milk you are morally and ethically
inconsistent
I spent probably eight hours straight on
Twitter I'm just watching people
tweeting about the show so I'd talk to
all these people who are like uh Adam
what a [ __ ] you can disagree with what
someone is saying about you but you have
to listen to them
I would I would tweet back doesn't be
like yeah I know he's horrible people
were so nice what you once you talk to
them so I found it really really fun to
talk to people like that people told me
what celebrities I look like the guy
from Despicable Me some kid from The
Wonder Years lankey Mark Zuckerberg I
reckon you're about 27 20 I'm 24 years
old people gave me a hard time for
having a large nose at first it's like
uh here comes Adam preceded by his big
nose like five minutes before him as the
episode went on they focused most of
their vitriol towards Peter because he
was obviously the villain the only
flavor left in my mouth is bitterness
and that's why I'm given a three Oh
Chris I challenge you to rap about
cookies and milk hmm America and
meltdowns cool cookies and milk America
and meltdown let's go to work
go to work like the Seven Dwarfs hi-ho
I like to get lactose with the Oreo I
twist them yeah give them a lick dip and
deep in the glass and milk oh so slick I
find that the lactose sugar makes me
admire I feel like all my sweet taste
buds are on fire we'll not technically
sweet do a favor and everybody
understand it all five flavors across
the tongue now almost got it wrong like
people who don't feel the cookies and
milk should dunk people don't put them
in they missing out I'd be like get your
cookie milk otherwise you about to
explode about to go crown when you feel
sad with the total meltdown
I'd be like stressed like an out of work
actor have a meltdown like a nuclear
reactor when I rosin is so cool in the
Land of the Rising Sun I'm not gonna
make a joke about the nuclear fission
because that will put me in a hate in
position I'm just saying from the Japan
I do it with these I got the whiff of
Hiroshima on the breeze and who did that
back in the day we know it was the you
USA I say you USA cuz you represent the
country I hope that you feeling crumbly
and hungry I give you some milk as a
peace offering Donald Trump he was never
properly anything to those when he gave
this speech but here we go don't want to
impeach I just say gas won't bribe or
backhand you I just say maybe vote for
Sanders when the who beat gofer die try
and write it anyway I take even the
Clinton Hillary as the leader of the
free world then she won't put us down
down a swirl the toilet down here
type of Fukushima we are we're over dead
hey con at it don't watch these in Japan
I see my kitchen stuff especially not